como se ha visto la muerte de la reina
desde argentina a propósito de la guerra
de las malvinas y la llegada de carlos
terceros
bien bueno creo que por supuesto la
cuestión malvinas sin ninguna duda de
que una de las cuestiones más sensibles
que tenemos en la argentina
argentina hoy tiene un territorio en una
parte de su territorio ocupado por un
ejército extranjero como es el caso de
las islas malvinas por una potencia
colonial como en gran bretaña eso es
algo que está claro y la el reclamo por
la soberanía de las malvinas para
nosotros es absoluta y completamente
irrenunciable además respaldado con la
resolución 2625 de naciones unidas' de
todas maneras creo que se vio y se vivió
en general y por lo que se ve también en
el tratamiento mediático más allá por
supuesto de algunas
excepciones y también por todo el arco
político argentino con respeto con mucho
respeto sobre todo nuevo porque en la
muerte en ese sentido no nos iguala
igual a todos y además la figura de
isabel segunda más allá de la cuestión
malvinas nos genera
pero no se lave demasiado como la
artífice en aquel momento de lo que fue
la guerra sino que más bien esa
responsabilidad recae por supuesto sobre
la junta militar argentina de la
dictadura militar del 82 que en aquel
momento y sobre margaret thatcher no a
quien se la acusa de por ejemplo un
crimen de guerra como fueron dimiento
del crucero general belgrano pero la
isabel segunda no no se le pone en este
rol sino que en las culpas entre
comillas recaen sobre otras figuras y la
sensibilidad está más tendiente a pensar
sobre otras figuras de britania como el
caso de thatcher no tanto sobre y saber
por lo que se vivió con mucho respeto y
las condolencias fueron expresadas por
absolutamente todo el arco político todo
el arco político argentino y
precisamente sobre la actuación de el
gobierno argentino hablemos que ni el
presidente alberto fernández ni su
canciller santiago cafiero están en el
funeral allí sólo está el embajador
argentino en reino unido esta
representación
o es también un mensaje político que se
envía
bueno creo que claramente se envía un
mensaje político en este que en este
caso del gobierno argentino hacia el
gobierno británico más allá de esto
bueno creo que en el último tiempo que
ha habido un hecho
un importante respeto cuando alberto
fernández se había reunido con el ex
primer ministro boris johnson y boris
johnson le dijo que no hay nada que
discutir sobre el tema malvinas en ese
sentido nada de eso está clara la
posición británica al al respecto
entonces el gobierno argentino no tiene
muchas más herramientas más que reclamar
en el organismo internacional le voy
mostrar alguna manera este tipo este
tipo de gestos de todas maneras está
representado por el embajador argentino
alberto fernández estaba había viajado a
nueva york a la cumbre de naciones
unidas y reuniones con kristalina
georgieva en los días previos del fondo
monetario internacional esto responde
más también a la coyuntura política
propia interna de argentina y las
necesidades internas argentinas respecto
de la relación con el fondo monetario
por la cuestión de la deuda entonces hay
también algunas otras explicaciones
políticas que exceden a la cuestión del
fallecimiento de isabel segunda más allá
del mensaje político que se ha querido
enviar o no